a lot of people arriving in South Sudan
are trying to get here
in paluch those who fled the fighting in
Sudan days or weeks before them told
them to come here and board evacuation
planes
wal came from Sudan's capital Khartoum
she says she's been stuck at the airport
for more than a week I have four kids
it's been hard pushing through the
crowds to get on a plane
living here is rough there's no shelter
water or adequate toilet facilities
I want to transport them the government
have provided four plane a day four big
jumbo plane as you can see a day and
that is a good capture from the
government side eight agencies say more
than 30 000 refugees and returnees have
reached South Sudan but not everyone is
registered and numbers are thought to be
higher so that's why we are working
still together with other
s most of the borders of South Sudan are
very remote they do not have
infrastructure that can be able to
accommodate these people
many new arrivals came with very few
belongings or money they need help to
get to where they need to go
the days are getting agitated and
frustrated they say they want to get out
of here but there aren't enough flights
available
more people are still crossing the
border this group of foreigners are
being taken to a refugee camp they've
managed to get out of Sudan but like so
many others they face an uncertain
future
South Sudan
meanwhile Qatar has sent a third plane